LCP vous donne rendez-vous pour une
grande émission spéciale élections
législative 2022 toute la chaîne se
mobilise pour vous faire vivre cet
événement plus de 4 heures de direct
pour tout connaître des résultats
découvrir le nouveau visage de
l'Assemblée nationale grâce à nos
nombreux correspondants en région un peu
partout en France dans les
circonscriptions clés et en plateau des
politologues des géographes des
constitutionnalistes pour analyser les
résultats et tirer les conséquences de
ce scrutin l'émission spéciale premier
tour des élections législatives
présentées par Brigitte boucher et
Myriam en Kawa dimanche en direct dès
19h30